hey 42 here in 1928 a scientist who
worked in a lab in London returned from
his summer holidays after a month his
name was Alexander Fleming he was a
horrendously messy and unorganized
scientist and he had left a large pile
of petri dishes shoved to the side of
his desk whilst he was on holiday upon
his return he discovered that one
particular petri dish had grown a new
bacteria which probably entered through
a nearby window Fleming discovered that
this new growth of mold was penicillium
notatum and amazingly it had killed the
growth of the existing bacteria
staphylococci Fleming could have simply
thrown out the contaminated culture but
instead he studied it and grew many more
of them since then trillions of
antibiotics have been produced and this
is estimated that over 200 million lives
have been saved thanks to Fleming's
accidental discovery it has been said
that of a butterfly flaps its wings in
China
it could cause a hurricane in New Mexico
this is known as the butterfly effect or
chaos theory in reality it's completely
false that a butterfly flapping its
wings can cause a hurricane on the other
side of the planet but this often quoted
poetic example is just a metaphor for
the true power of the butterfly effect
it was discovered and named by
meteorologist Edward Lorenz in 1969 he
was running mathematical models trying
to predict the exact path of tornadoes
he noticed that the results would change
drastically as a result of tiny
alterations to the initial conditions of
the experiment when he ran the
simulation hundreds of times he noticed
that the plotted results looked like the
wings of a butterfly loose he named it
the butterfly effect now if we go back
for a moment to Alexander Fleming and
his accidental discovery that has saved
hundreds of millions of lives this is a
perfect example of
the butterfly effect in action a tiny
seemingly insignificant decision such as
not throwing away a moldy petri dish has
altered the course of history beyond
recognition and sent humanity down a
completely different path just think
about those many millions of people that
lived due to Fleming's decision and more
importantly what those millions of
people have done to change the world
themselves creating their own butterfly
effects Winston Churchill's life was
saved by antibiotics when he suffered
from pneumonia in Cairo in 1943 in the
final years of the war when Britain's
outlook was bleak and many doubted if
victory against the tyranny of Nazism
could even be accomplished
it was Churchill's most powerful
uplifting and inspiring speeches that
brought a country and its allies
together in strength and solidarity
against evil in these final days almost
all of the most powerful figures in
Britain's government and around Europe
wanted to negotiate a surrender with
Germany and make peace but Churchill's
dogged defiance fought on regardless
whilst there are many variables that led
to an Allied victory it can be argued
that if Churchill had not been saved by
antibiotics then the world would look
very different today but that's just one
life penicillin and other antibiotics
were used to save countless lives during
World War two who all went on to affect
the outcome of the war in their own way
and the post-war world as well
in fact even Hitler's life was saved by
penicillin on the 20th of July 1944
klaus von stauffenberg attempted to
assassinate the Fuehrer using an
explosion he was unsuccessful but it all
suffered life-threatening injuries and
resulting infections that before the
advance of penicillin would have killed
him
Hitler was treated with high grade
penicillin
saving his life so that he would lead
his fascist army for another year until
he took his own life
but the really ironic part of this story
is that the very penicillin used to save
Hitler was inadvertedly supplied by the
British the Germans did have their own
penicillin but it wasn't strong enough
to have saved Hitler's life these are
just a couple of examples of the power
of the butterfly effect tiny decisions
we make every day could have
unfathomably huge effects on the future
maybe ten fifty or a thousand years from
now that is the very nature of the
highly chaotic system that we live it
it's why the weather is phenomenally
difficult to predict and so is the stock
market they are both chaotic systems
where there are billions of variables
and a tiny change to just one variable
can completely alter the outcome of the
entire system why don't you make a small
change today that could change the
destiny of your life by learning a brand
new skill skill sure is an online
learning community with more than 17,000
classes in design writing film
production web development whatever you
want to learn a premium membership gives
you unlimited access to high-quality
classes from experts working in their
fields so you can improve your skills
unlock new opportunities and do the work
you love I really enjoyed watching simon
Sinek Skillshare course presentation
essentials how to share ideas that
inspire action anyone who's interested
in public speaking video production or
teaching should definitely head over to
skill share and watch this fascinating
course an annual subscription to skilled
share premium is less than $10 per month
but because skill share have kindly
sponsored this video I'm excited to
offer that for a limited time only you
can get your first free monster
Skillshare for only 99 cents if you
click the link in the description but
this offer is only available until the
end of January so click the link below
to
over there and try it out now the
chaotic system of humanity demonstrated
its true power when George Bush was
elected president of the United States
in 1999 a young Cuban boy called Elian
Gonzales and his mother were attempting
to flee Cuba and reach the United States
via the water during the crossing to
Florida Ellen's mother drowned a lien
reached America and was taken in by
relatives who already lived there but
elion father back in Cuba soon spoke out
to the press that he wanted his son to
return to Cuba which was at the time
still under the presidency of communist
Fidel Castro the Clinton administration
were quick to decide that aliens should
return to his father in Cuba but the
large Cuban community in Florida
campaign to let aliens stay in the US as
they thought that he would have a safer
and happier life but the Clinton
administration ignored the wishes of the
Cuban community and sent a SWAT team to
raid their home of aliens relatives in
Miami and forcibly remove him then
deported him back to Cuba Bill Clinton
received much criticism for this move in
response to this when it came to the
2000 election over 50,000 voters from
the Florida Cuban community who were
usually Democratic voters switched their
votes to the Republican Party
choosing to vote for George Bush instead
of Al Gore in protest of the decision
taken by the Democratic Bill Clinton
administration over one small boy from
Cuba and as a result of this protest
vote by one community but warned the
state of Florida by a miniscule 537
votes out of a total six million cast
the overall result was ridiculously
close and despite losing the popular
vote Bush won a presidential election by
a tiny margin many experts have said
that if the Elian Gonzalez
incident hadn't had happened and a small
community in Florida hadn't has switched
their votes then George Bush would have
lost Florida hands lost the election
making Al Gore president and in true
butterfly effect style the ramifications
of this one small boy on a boat have
been beyond huge bush has been blamed
for a handful of world-changing events
including the Iraq war which many argue
led to the eventual rise of Isis now you
may be thinking if a seemingly
insignificant decision that you or even
somebody else makes can vastly alter the
course of your future do you really have
control over your own life this is an
age-old mystery that many a famous
physicist has attempted to answer and to
answer that we have to ask the question
is time deterministic that means no
matter what we do we cannot change the
future it is already decided for us or
is it the case that we can change the
future
ie is time in deterministic Albert
Einstein believed in determinism he
theorized that we have no free will and
that future itself is already written
for us time is not something that we are
creating but instead we are on a train
called the present and we are traveling
the longer set of rails called time but
the exact path of those rails has
already been decided for us this
generally made a lot of people very
angry because as humans we don't like to
feel like we aren't in control of our
own destinies but then came quantum
mechanics and that changed everything
groundbreaking experiments such as the
double-slit experiments and the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle made
the physics community think differently
when we observe atoms up close they
behave very strangely indeed although
they would appear to be particles like
grains of sand they don't behave as such
they instead behave like a wave and a
particle at the very same time in 1927
German physicist Werner Heisenberg came
up with the idea that in the quantum
world we cannot know the exact location
of an object at any one time we can only
make an educated prediction at where it
is likely to be in space and time to
summarise atoms are really fuzzy and
random in their behavior
the effective Heisenberg's discovery led
the majority of the scientific community
to switch their consensus about
determinism and so today most physicists
believe that the future is not
predetermined and we do have free will
contrary to Einsteins remarks and this
makes the butterfly effect even more
powerful because you have the power even
if you don't realize it too hugely
altered the course of the future for all
of mankind something stupidly
insignificant like taking a wrong turn
on the road or saying hello to a
stranger can cause huge ripples in time
though you would never realize it at the
time and you think I'm being dramatic by
saying that you could change the world
by simply taking a wrong turn
well that is precisely what started two
world wars on the 28th of June 1914
Archduke Franz Ferdinand ate lunch at a
delicatessen in Sarah Hara when he left
the deli
Ferdinand's driver took a wrong turn and
accidentally drove past an assassin
named Gavrilo Princip now Princip had
carefully planned to assassinate
franz ferdinand and he had guessed what
his route home might have been from the
deli but he had guessed the wrong route
if Ferdinand's driver hadn't have taken
a wrong turn the car would have never
driven past the would-be assassin and
the assassination wouldn't have taken
place but alas he did take a wrong turn
giving Princip the perfect opportunity
to fatally shoot Ferdinand Franz
Ferdinand's assassination had a domino
effect on world politics which started
World War one
so if Franz Ferdinand's driver hadn't
had accidentally taken the wrong turn
it's very likely that World War one
would never have happened at all and
without World War one there would have
been no World War two no Hitler no
Holocaust no cold war maybe the atom
bomb wouldn't have been invented there
would also be no internet today and
likely no personal computers either
because military pressure drove both of
these technological advancements but war
also significantly advanced medicine
which would be nowhere near as advanced
as it is today
sans world wars also had the wars never
happened
ironically Germany would probably be the
world's leading cultural scientific and
economic powerhouse today and its rapid
advancement as a nation would have been
completely unimpeded and with no
military pressure to keep up the United
States would have fallen behind this is
just an overview it's impossible to list
all the differences there would be in
the world today had that driver not
taken a wrong turn and the fact that the
future rests on events so seemingly
insignificant is in equal measures both
beautiful and terrifying thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon and if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe also don't forget to
check out Skillshare by clicking the
link in the description